So now we've divided our search engine code into two modules, the crawler that
builds the corpus this is everything we can do before the query. The search
engine, that responds to query, this is everything that we do after a query
starting with a known corpus. We're going to add a third module which we'll call
test.py. That uses these two, that does some test building a corpus using our
lucky search and ordered search to do some queries. So now the question is how
do we need to set up imports to make this work? So here are the choices: search
needs to import crawler, crawler needs to import search, test needs to import
crawler, test needs to import search, search needs to import test. Check all of
the ones that are true.